what's your ideal Christmas like now
good food and more food
[Music]
so guys it's the holidays I want to do
like a new tradition this year I want to
do a photo challenge so we have these
Samsung gear 360s we're gonna take a
holiday photo or video and you're gonna
capture all the feels in the photo I'm
gonna win this no one's gonna win this
year other than me no we're winning
ah we'll see about that so guys when I
was a kid growing up you see a roller
skating all the time I know a lot of us
aren't at home for the holidays and a
lot of us live far away so I was
thinking maybe this can be like our
tradition moving forward
is just like our local family this is
like right below eating glazed ham for
me
[Music]
[Music]
no longer need the person with the long
arm that was the guy right it's always
like oh sorry long arm guy that thing
shot where his face is extra close
enough booze put in the center of the
living room everyone's in the shop did
any of you guys have your family pet in
the Christmas card my dog can only like
see his back because he's never faced
the camera I feel like I'm a kid again 3
2 1 cheese
[Music]
[Applause]
all right captain what treaty you want
we're not gonna pay for you 20 peon
though that's just not right on my
wallet did you have trees hey you guys
this place we didn't have real trees but
I wish we did because they smell really
good my food here we go your Nana will
get to see the whole experience I shall
say the trees
[Music]
there we go my Christmas card holidays I
love all the colors all the masks
[Music]
Oh like all of them that's my mom
oh yeah
[Music]
oh that's really cool we think a funny
thing about it seriously
[Music]
hey Tiffany I'm starting at your house
alrighty oh look if there's your whole
family more family members you have a
big family okay we're moving on to the
Christmas tree shopping Wow these pearly
whites she looks so happy
look at you look at your little pub and
that view the mountains gorgeous that's
really good it's your turn roller rink
this is a video I like this you put the
camera on the ground so if you have to
turn it up you see our wonderful disco
ball on the light this is gonna be tough
I think we need a drumroll there can
only be one winner that is Tiffany the
reason being everything was right there
I just got like the full feeling of
being with your family in your home so
great work I'm sharing it to my social
Thank You it all said you guys did a
wonderful job that was very hard for me
treats for all of us
[Applause]
[Music]